اذا مشاهدينا نحن امامنا الان قرش النمر
كما ترون هذه ثاني اخطر اسماك القرش يفضل
هذا النوع المياه الدافئه والمناطق
الاستوائيه والمعتدله ايضا وقد هاجم البشر
138 مره وقتلت 37 شخصا كان اخرهم الشاب
الروسي الذي نتحدث عنه يمكن ان يزن قرش
النمر قرابه الطن تقريبا يصل طول الى
اربعه امتار يطلق على سمكه قرش النمر
صندوق نفايات المحيط حيث ياكل اي شيء
تقريبا حي او ميت حتى المخلفات
البلاستيكيه
اسنانها فتاكه تطحن العظام بثوالم بسيط
لكن هناك ايضا مشاهدينا قرش اخر وهو اكثر
فتكا القرش الابيض الكبير وهو اخطر انواع
سمك القرش وهو بطل افلام جاز اذا كنتم
تذكرونها في السبعينيات هاجم 354 شخصا حول
العالم وتسبب في مقتل 57 منهم هذا النوع
يزن طنين ونصف الطن لديه 100 الاسنان
الحاده ياكل 14 كيلو جراما من اللحم في
قضمه واحده لكن هذا القاتل المخيف لم يبقى
منه الا
3500 فقط وهذا القاتل المخيف لديه من يقتل
وهو الحوت القاتل لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات